today we're gonna find out which one of
you guys is the hottest tri guy
scientifically of course science baby
what actually makes a man attractive
today more than ever society and media
appreciate hot men like us for instance
and we wondered if that sexiness could
be boiled down to a science
we're here to find out if the prevailing
theories about male beauty have any
truth to them and we hear the test
subjects the try guys are going to be
conducting six experiments gonna draw
blood measure our faces I'm gonna win
all the categories today beautiful
beautiful Keith in the rest
where would we fall hundred be the best
one being the worst you've ever seen in
the bottom 5% mmm woof this is a little
tough but if it means anything to you I
would happily penetrate each and every
one of you guys and since we're best
buds and already know we're all super
freakin hot we decided to frame our
series of experiments the way only the
try guys can as a game show its which
try guy is scientifically the hottest
with your ultra bangable host my name is
dr. curly so you have the results I do
have the results your nan stick each of
you guys were ranked go ever gets the
lowest number is the sexier so it's like
the golf of hotness so I hope I'm at
least on par with the other guy
now the first category is testosterone
is based on aggression this will
probably go to Ned it's a very
aggressive person it's all [ __ ]
testosterone is linked to body hair and
to hair loss you boys that got both of
those I think that I'm gonna win this
category because I have a ton of sperm
in my blood whenever I get my blood
taken out they're like wow testosterone
is a very important element if a man
doesn't have any testosterone he loses a
lot of characteristics that makes him a
man the thing again good to see you Joe
so I think the last time we were
together we did semen analysis on you
and we learned a lot about you what's
your on vein percentage are you bad in
the hundreds I don't want a sakes I'll
jinx myself into a simple blood test
when we get it throughout to the
accurate measurement and figure out
where women are in the spectrum I bet
you a sperm has gotten into blood once
in the legs whooping what a bad life
Eugene doesn't love needles shut up yeah
it's like my veins I levels of
testosterone think you have a very high
sex drive muscle mass is another thing I
do giving me blood my blood is very
selfish if you look at it from that
perspective then he may appear more
attractive oh you have to go back to the
right side take a look are you [ __ ]
serious right now
I'm not cow it's still inside of me 91
how much sperm is typically in the
bloodstream zero makes sense right yeah
makes no sense at all so we have the
results I know a lot of guys look like
that oh wow the runner-up for the
mostest awesome is keeper
there's so much room in my life yeah
number one didn't it's usually I uh
have you seen our hair elixir I do have
very very sexy the zabi don't worry dad
I don't really thought med would be
number one no scientific data that
correlates the level of testosterone to
the level of attractiveness but
certainly there's something there this
is supposed to be my category yeah yeah
BMI BMI is pretty specific it measures
your fat this comes down to mere nest so
maybe I'll win V enough that's got that
big old fight and that's gonna weigh him
down I think that I'm gonna win this
category I got the most mats in my body
but I think what piss off before your
BMI is one way to calculate overall fat
levels in a guy 70.2 136 on the time 167
on the don't know anyone Mallory the
higher your body mass index is means
that you're wider than you are tall I
remember in high school having low BMI
but never people fit you can have a
really low BMI but it doesn't tell you
anything about his cardiovascular
fitness I mean those who are the most
fit we're the most diverse in size so
the general population is better to have
a low BMI than the high BMI
let's hear these results and if it makes
you feel any better there's a whole gay
community that loves shrubby guys so
you're in with us okay
runner up your game come on you know it
[Applause]
my body's hotter than Eugene's Wow Wow
look at the you know number three it's a
relatively okay surrogate for men's
health but it's not perfect what kind of
exercise you get I play soccer I'm going
to CrossFit we have a lot of stairs in
the office and sometimes I go between
floors
yone check this out I'm less flabby
imagine an NFL running back those guys
have a terrible body mass index but
nobody's gonna tell them they're not in
shape they're stacked though bro
thanks man about to break beautiful face
we're gonna take photos of our faces and
see who's got the best face a very
delicate features I'm very precious I'm
the most mutual features I've been
referred to as fat other white guys I
think that I'm gonna win this category
because I have a great face facial
attractiveness is way more than just
whether or not somebody's hot or not
facial attractiveness has to do with a
variety of characteristics ranging from
the width of someone's face to the
distance between their eyes the distance
between their nose and their mouth let's
look at Keith look this is my normal
face
[Applause]
and then this side is my right side
well a little do fear yeah sort of wider
well nobody can obviously be perfect we
would ideally like to have the most
symmetrical features see the left guy
[Music]
you see these side-by-side again this
guy looks like a dupe and this guy looks
just so sexy
we all have them but they exist Heath
has very nice but deep set eyes and the
distance between them is relatively
small which isn't necessarily the most
appealing I would definitely say that
he's yours more towards a stronger
jawline which is a very strong signal of
reproductive health
so go key let's talk about that this is
normal me so here this is just my left
side nerd he's a jock look I got rugby
playing yeah I'm like for the end of
that it looks taller the other side must
be worse than cam and this is the right
side
I don't like this version to me at the
literal egghead this is my left side so
that means that's my good side yeah so
Zach's face is relatively cheap when we
look at the tip of his nose to the top
of his forehead we're able to see the
doc has a relatively larger forehead
better than the average individual so
exact hasn't we like to call a natural
lip and that's really a very attractive
feature and very much a strong signal of
biological fitness what's attractive
about a tiny mouth no put anything in
there so here's my face the transporter
3 starring Eugene Lee yang am I the
person who gets transported no no you
see like he's transporting Asians this
is the left side of my face very
symmetrical we can has a relatively high
degree of facial symmetry and I think
that's something important to understand
right side oh the difference is pretty
my new it makes it creepier the boy
we're gonna get at the more disturbing
these look like the evil clone versions
of Nathan universe is one side of Zach's
face one side of my face duplicated look
better your normal face looks better
than both sides independently the length
between his nose and chin is very much
consistent with what we would consider
to be facially attractive Eugene has a
very very interesting jawline it's very
strong but at the same time it gives a
softness as well so I'd like to say he
has a medium jawline sona is a very
attractive man
there's my normal face so your
expressionless to camera always looks
like you just kind of farted and are
trying to cover it oh yeah I pardon all
my passport photos this is the left side
you look thinner on this side you look
like you haven't slept in years
that's a championship soccer player
right there yeah and this is the right
side
really different I do see how different
your noses on each side from breaking my
nose either of these quite look like it
divided him into his academic side his
sporty side that has a relatively longer
distance between his nose and the top of
his forehead which is not considered to
be most conventionally attractive Matt
has the softest draw a line of all the
men which makes him the most desirable
in terms of long term partnership so if
somebody says you look like you're
married it makes total sense the
ovulatory period women are more
attracted to men who are going to
exhibit higher characteristics related
to biological fitness like testosterone
whereas other times of the month when
they're not ovulating they're sneaking
out partners who appear to be more kind
and passionate and may be attracted to
men with a softer jawline the runner-up
the most beautiful face in the try guys
[Music]
wait my lips are better than cracking
apart they're literally bleeding right
now ready for number one you Queen
Eugene I don't think I'm the
best-looking I think we're all very
good-looking number three you're still
beautiful Matt thank you so don't you
wait which makes me the most unique so
I'm the best look Wow so I'm the hottest
white tri guy Wow no I don't know all
right guys so this category is pheromone
my wife said let's smell great I think I
have vo we'll see I think I'm gonna win
this category I think I'm gonna win this
category because it's not great shirt in
the bed it's time to make this t-shirt
smell like this man the try guys wore
shirts for an entire week to bed I'm too
tired to do this flag right now cares
I'm wearing the same shirt every day
okay good May if you look good across
the room and the closer you get
is there any repulsive or more
attractive factors and that's where
pheromones come up but they're very
difficult to measure you don't know
exactly we're gonna let our colleagues
smell our shirts anonymously to find out
who has the best natural Manset nurse
not bad I think a maybe smells a little
sweaty er then I would have liked it
smelled of cold cuts it hit me in the
nose like a baseball bat a single
delicious I like it because it smells
like a dude I could not smell anything
on be a ghost for that shirt not a man
oh I like to be much better than inking
it just was the freshest my least
favorite I think was B he shows that me
like I don't like this guy see I was
like I want to be that guy's friend sees
my favorite really yes like after sex
shower smell I remember things that were
worse and it was definitely sandy I
don't agree I liked Dean I just had like
a nice calming smell do you was my
favorite he would take you to a Crab
Shack on the beach do you gotta smell
like gold it was like best to worse
really I feel the other way around you
try guys are known for a lot of things
and smelling bad is not one of it was
really not much out there in the
scientific literature so yeah go for it
by all means don't let science get in
the way of a really good time
number two yeah my wife does like my
smash does that got third and I lost
what's next all the gay men like to
smell the most funny it's not a bit more
masculine thank you the bottom line is
it just comes down to how they smell
that's what brings them together is that
global smell rather than some molecular
attraction I honestly feel like each you
guys have like a different thing that is
like really sexy that I'm like I could
hit it I could hit it we could do this
guy's tinder
I have done a lot of videos about tinder
if I don't win this category it is
[ __ ] pathetic I think I'm gonna win
this category because I take a lot of
good photos people love looking at me on
the Internet
tinder is the internet attractiveness is
a very holistic measure trying to
understand someone's personality where
they come from and where they're going
now we're gonna all set up tinder
profile I've never created an online
dating app ever
well you're not creating an app you're
putting a profile see I already can't
use words correctly none the other guy's
never done this before I'm excited I
think you're gonna like it I think
there's some things you won't like so in
theory that should have this what do you
think this photo says about you Zach my
first photo me looking hot looking off
to the side it's cute I got style
but I'm approachable number one you're
wearing glasses and volume of very nice
glasses you've reduced the likelihood of
being swiped right over a 15 percent by
wearing a hat you're reducing your like
lewd or being spied on by 12 percent
because it also obstructs your eyes by
facing forward you increase your
likelihood of being spread on by 20
percent
hi I'm losing percentages like crazy
right yes your stock values plummeting I
read in a different online dating book
that men's photos perform better when
they look off-cam I would argue with my
PhD which took six years in my research
at tinder and interviewing people
globally about online dating that I
might know just a little more I met my
wife before online dating was the things
I have absolutely zero experience making
profiles I found it very hard to find
photos of just me this whole thing feels
weird but here we go here's one it's me
and a cool Florentine jacket next to a
line of Vespas Oh is he 18% Italian I
don't know let's find out are you in
Italy or in Europe I am in Italy or
Europe so that's a good conversation
starter people are going to want to know
more about you this is wonderful except
they're not smiling in the first photo
yes because it makes you seem kind and
approachable I want to remain totally
unreliable generally in life so it's
tender enough people who smirk over
smiling and are potentially evil inside
that gets into a more philosophical
question about whether people are
fundamentally evil this is one of my
best friend's babies if you can see the
baby is terrified me
okay so now I'm finding child services
this is working even people who don't
necessarily want children don't want a
witness abuse I don't think I'm abusing
the baby the baby just wants to get away
from me to the left if you don't come up
to my profile and be like I want what
he's having fried chicken
your fool chicken and biscuits okay
[Applause]
you've got cardiovascular disease on
your mind
that was good yes exactly this is
nothing about you just went huge on
Twitter so I'm tap it in so you did
something that went huge on Twitter I
didn't I recreated it but don't you want
to be original and lead with your own
lines with your own story a rusty
bathtub outside wow this guy likes to
have fun I didn't know that you were
outside I just thought you wanted to get
tetanus no I already have my vaccination
oh that's what do you think this photo
says about you that I like standing
against dumpsters I hate this I'm cute
as [ __ ] that photo
I'm smiling kindly you're not smiling
kindly you look like you're up to
something up to kindness let's go on is
that a Hebrew character on your necklace
okay that army any points I'm Jewish
not particularly in this contact okay
how about this one oh this look at all
the girls to swipe right Oh photo of you
with your wife on your wedding day
you're abusing animals the dog looks
like it's being tortured in the back
having a great time this is my head as a
cake I think this we can skip my bio we
don't know never do you dirt dirt dirt a
Rihanna lyric are you Rihanna people
love RiRi
I like white wine and traveling the
world let's split a bottle and get to
know each other and I like white way to
traveling the world but we may have
nothing in common let's split a bottle
and talk about it loves dogs heat baby
should I have written more Haley these
let's fall in love each day that passes
with each of
remaining alone is one less day of bliss
hisses yo future heart it's poetic I
have analyzed thousands and thousands
and thousands of profiles the scale of 1
to 100
where would ours fall in the bottom 5%
woof woof it's a race for last place on
tinder all of us suck at it I thought
I'd be at the end of my career when I
got roasted but apparently it happened
now so they're running around that exact
remember you were still in the bottom 5%
of all of tinder this is really a hollow
victory number one is keep thank God
because I'm worse than pick a child
abuser I would be very upset guys I
think we all had very fun cute profiles
I would swipe right oh no me too
I think that attractiveness is very
classical I think you could find
somebody to be very attractive but they
may not necessarily be a person with
whom you connect okay so we asked all of
our co-workers internationally which of
you guys was physically the hottest
gigantic
this survey is not just 305 we're
pulling a pitbull it's mr. worldwide now
we have offices everywhere this is an
interesting one they know what I think
I'm gonna win this one
because everyone likes ready for theirs
oh wow to me that's you to Eugene the
only one that could actually put it now
all those children are right look I've
already had several four places you've
had nine I couldn't take another you
can't call me daddy the same sentence
take practice that you're not harder
than Eugene but maybe I can honor this
all relative I think your mouth shut the
[ __ ] up y'all ready for the second poll
wait there's another poll yeah there's a
secret pool to see which one of you guys
our co-workers thought was actually -
here we go
not based on looks curly if it's the
same exact order I'm gonna be really
bleep idiot
do not kick me why it's not a good
message we all know that that is a very
caring husband exactly handle me without
getting offended every day that can I
has the most similar sense of humor
and it seems like he'd be a good dude to
hang around I like someone like that
makes me laugh so maybe keep probably
Keith like Keith is just like so funny
and fun at the end of the day I just
want to watch Netflix with someone
I would date Zach because he would be
easy to control this is technically the
most important Bowl because all of the
looks need to wanting to have a
relationship nothing mattered and till
now on the tutorial technically husband
material number one the most datable I
also would want to date keep the most
yeah I would be the first strip number
three yeah yeah I think you're a great
person to be in a relationship with I
would date you yeah fan I wouldn't but
just because the whole Jewish Asian
thing is a stereotype I think we need a
break but think of the children how
successful they seem like yeah beautiful
the number one scientifically hottest
try guy is Eugene but no one wants to
have a baby with me plus if you hate on
this is very cheap number two is a tie a
tie between Ned and back
[Applause]
oh boy it's interesting to know that
there are scientific factors that
correlate to your attractiveness but
doesn't always correlate the how much
someone wants today what I love about
the try guys is they are willing to try
anything you can measure anything you
want down to the molecular level but at
the end of the day throw science out the
window and just be a drag to be
attracted to you guys have delicious
guys do you have any more questions
something our fans noticed last time we
were here was it would that now that
knife symbolizes six years of hard work
and thousands of operations that got me
through my training do you ever think
about how you waited for like the white
whale of penises that glass is breakable
so it just may be that I will find my
match break my piece of huge